nous lisons en moyenne 200 mots à la
minute anna jones a lu harry potter au
rythme de quatre mille mots à la minute
avec une excellente compréhension finale
elle a été six fois championne du monde
de la lecture rapide
salut pour ce master class nous allons
parler vous l'avez bien compris de
lecture rapide 200 mo 300 mots à la
minute c'est en moyenne à vitesse à
laquelle on lit du coup je me suis testé
il ya quelques années pour ça et je me
suis rendu compte que je lisais au
rythme de trois cent dix mots à la
minute avec un taux de compréhension de
47% 47% s'est pas beaucoup mais en fait
c'est la moyenne c'est là où j'ai
compris qu'on pouvait améliorer ça et il
ya carrément des concours de ça il ya
des méthodes pour lire plus rapidement
et c'est de ça dont on va parler
aujourd'hui notre première erreur quand
on lit ces deux lire mot-à-mot en sub
vocalisant c'est à dire qu'on se parle
intérieurement on lit mot-à-mot
intérieurement on a même des
micromouvements de gorge comme si on
était en train de parler on se raconte à
nous-mêmes seconde c'est une grosse
perte de temps à une grosse perte de
compréhension au final l'idée principale
de la lecture rapide c'est de faire
moins de mouvements oculaires
on le lit pas comme ça aussi simplement
on le lit comme ça on ne fait que de
revenir en arrière en permanence et
quasiment tous les deux mois on fixe le
regard pour bien comprendre il faut
passer ça déjà pour une lecture rapide
il faut se mettre dans un environnement
calme et bien éclairé au début quand
vous allez essayer d'appliquer les
techniques de lecture rapide vous allez
perdre du temps de lecture parce que
vous allez plus penser à appliquer les
méthodes qu'à lire ça c'est tout à fait
normal c'est une étape indispensable
entre le fait d'appliquer des méthodes
en y pensant et le fait d'appliquer des
méthodes naturellement une bonne chose à
faire qui prend pas trop de temps c'est
au lieu de s'arrêter tous les deux mots
essayer de se forcer à me fixer le
regard que tous les 4-5 mois environ
mais surtout en quelques minutes vous
pouvez augmenter par 1,5 voire par deux
votre rythme de lecture et votre rythme
de compréhension puisque plus on lit
vite mieux on comprend car plus on
synthétise ça paraît très étrange dit
comme ça mais c'est la réalité tout
d'abord contrairement à ce qu'on nous a
appris à l'école ce que nous a répété
c'est pas bien de dire avec son doigt
c'est pas vrai lisez avec votre doigt ou
avec un petit marque pages il vous faut
un guide de lecture c'est ce qui va
éviter aux yeux d'aller un petit peu au
dessus un petit peu en dessous de perdre
votre regard le guide c'est le plus
fonctionnel pour ça et en plus vous
allez vous donner vous même le rythme
avec votre doigt en le déplaçant de plus
en plus rapidement vous pouvez essayer
de dire comme ça durant cinq dix minutes
pour vous réhabituer une fois que vous
avez fait ça vous allait franchir une
autre étape
chaque page que vous allez commencer à
lire ou les paragraphes que vous allez
commencer à bien vous les lycées à
partir du quatrième au
ne vous embêtez pas avec les premiers et
vous allez voir que vous allez les
photographier les comprendre sans les
avoir lus ni subtilisé et de la même
manière arrêtez vous au milieu de la
dernière ligne de la page ou du
paragraphe votre cerveau de la
photographier il a enregisté le comprend
appliquer cette nouvelle technique à la
première dure encore 10 minutes
et au bout de ces dix minutes là donc ça
fait vingt minutes que vous avez déjà
amélioré votre temps de lecture et
forcez vous à nous fixer le regard que
deux fois par lignes maximum alors que
la plupart du temps vous arrêtez 7 8
voire 10 fois et déjà en appliquant ces
trois méthodes la c3 simple méthode est
en vous efforçant de le faire maintenant
à chaque fois vous allez améliorer votre
temps pour aller encore plus loin dans
ce master class je vous propose trois
choses il ya un site que j'utilise qui
s'appelle zappé reader c'est un site
gratuit il n'y a pas trop de pub ça va
il n'y a pas besoin de s'inscrire vous
copier coller le texte que vous voulez
lire là dedans ça peut être un mail ça
peut être un article sur internet peu
importe vous définissez votre vitesse de
lecture idéale et il va vous lui envoyez
vous le faire tourner en mode lecture
rapide ça va entraîner votre oeil et
surtout vous allez vous surprendre quand
vous allez voir à quel point vous lisez
rapidement et vous comprenez bien ce qui
se dit je vous mets évidemment le lien
dans le descriptif je vous mets aussi un
autre lien vers un autre site qui est
sûr mais examen.com c'est pareil a pas
besoin de s'inscrire ya pas trop de pub
c'est simplement un test pour définir
aujourd'hui votre vitesse de lecture
bateau de compréhension j'ai essayé ce
test c'est pas le meilleur qui existe
non plus mais il al avantage d gratuit
et enfin pour moi la bible à ce sujet je
vous en ai déjà parlé dans une vidéo
c'est tony buzan avec son livre sur la
lecture rapide je vous mets le lien
aussi dans le descriptif si vraiment
vraiment vraiment vous intéressez à la
lecture rapide et que vous voulez aller
jusqu'à 1000 mots à la minute c'est à
dire de 150 pages en une heure environ
avec une vraie bonne compréhension
je vous recommande ce bouquin la cia une
médiathèque près de chez vous peut-être
qu'ils l'ont si quelqu'un l'a fait le
vous prêtez c'est pas de l'incitation à
l'acheter mais mes de l'incitation à
vous procurer et vous le dire je vous
mets le lien comme ça vous aurez toute
la référence j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu je vous assure que la lecture
rapide c'est passionnant si vous vous y
mettez un petit peu au moins les trois
points que je vous ai donné tout à
l'heure essayez de le faire merci en
tout cas d'avoir regardé si ça vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir
en laissant un petit mais rapide pouce
en l'air n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit commentaire puisque évidemment je
les lis tous et ça m'intéresse à chaque
fois vous me donner des idées n'hésitez
pas à les mettre vos idées aussi pour
lire plus vite ou d'autres masters cas
ce que vous voulez partager aussi cette
vidéo si vous pensez que ça peut
intéresser d'autres personnes et
abonnez-vous à la chaîne puisque le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous
à 11h ciao